the backlash continues as the Kardashian
family comes to terms with Rob's new
relationship on tuesday ET exclusively
reported that Rob's family is in shock
that the reclusive star is dating Tigers
former fiancee blac Chyna now a source
close to Rob tells ET the family is
afraid the model is doing this for
attention ET has reached out to blac
Chyna for comment our source says quote
the problem in this situation is no one
wants to push too hard on Rob because of
his fragile state things with him moves
slowly so they never push anything the
source adds that the 28 year old is
still overweight and that he has not
been working out regularly or eating
well rob is good rob is back at the
house he's good ET sat down with his
sister Khloe earlier this month where
she gave us an update on Rob following
his diabetes diagnosis my only hope is
is that maybe this health scare is a
wake-up call and it was just you know
adjust his life and be more serious
about certain things in his life